جوله جديده من العراق السياسي سببها هذه
المره تقرير حكومي امريكي حول منشا فيروس
كورونا من انه خرج بسبب حادث من مختبر
صيني في وهران وفق تقرير لموقع اكسيوس فان
الكشف عن منشا كورونا زاد من حده التوتر
بين الولايات المتحده والصين وطرح تململا
واستياء كبيرين في اوساط الاعضاء البارزين
في الحزب الجمهوري الذين لطالما وجهوا
اصابع الاتهام حيث يرون بان النتيجه التي
تم الكشف عنها من طرف مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الامريكي تثبت انهم كانوا على
حق طوال الوقت الماضي بخصوص تسرب الفيروس
من مختبر صيني لم يكن عن قصد ولم يكن ضمن
برنامج عسكري تعمل عليه بيكين وانما بسبب
حادث لم تتضح اسبابه بعد لكن التقرير يطحن
كل النظريات تزامنت مع الجائحه والقى
باللوم على الصين بانها وراء الوباء ما
يفتح الباب مستقبلا للمحاسبه والتعويض بعد
التقرير ارتفعت الاصوات المطالبه بالسياسه
اكثر صرامه مع الصين بدفع من الخلافات
التي تشهدها العلاقات بين واشنطن وبيكين
كل ذلك والصين ترفض الاتهامات لكنها وحتى
الان لم تقدم اي تفسير او دليل على مصدر
الفيروس